de tout temps la naissance à l'art à la
barre
les hommes ont noué avec la ou des
essences émission en relation
l'arbre source d'inspiration de daniel
covenants une passion de la peinture de
toujours devenue vitale
en 1993 un accident vasculaire cérébral
paralyse entièrement tout le côté droit
de son corps
la peinture l'aide alors à s'exprimer
donc je suis entré dans la dans le trop
de larmes
pourquoi le tronc tout simplement parce
que c'est le trait d'union entre les
racines idéal maison où j'étais et le
feuillage vers la lumière
j'espère arriver c'était pour moi
à prouver aux autres que d'un gréement
marché c'est comme un arrêté pendant des
heures de peinture le jour la nuit sans
cesse après 24 ans de pratiquer un
passage par les beaux-arts par pont-aven
il revient dans les yvelines
il y a dix ans il se met à peindre avec
du bitume
j'ai fait un essai je me suis rendu
compte que c'était c'était rapide
j'étais touché par la profondeur du noir
très très chaud très profond le but
c'est tout est aussi la leçon du temps
aussi parce que le bitume
ça vient du putois le pétrole lui même
ça vient des taux un d'eux a roulé tout
ça donc ça ça retour à la naissance une
renaissance qu'il présente assez vite un
premier tableau exposé à paris une
soixantaine à guyancourt
une vingtaine d'années plus tôt ses
oeuvres sont toutes autres celle ci
d'accord ils maîtrisent un petit bout et
ça ça ne peut que voilà ça représente ma
main est ce que vous êtes droitier et
celle en rade droite
c'est symbolique mais sur ses mains
nouées parce que j'étais parisé par
contre des roses or il ya encore du
ressort dans la tête
le figuratif et la peinture à l'huile
sont ses premières amours
jusqu'à sa découverte de fabienne
verdier une artiste abstraite dont la
spiritualité fait écho à celle de daniel
covenants des croyances des espoirs des
rêves
enfin important c'est le produit jeunes
sur la toile parce que ça vient de moi
même c'est dès ce n'est pas comme un
figuratif ou où on fait quelque chose
qu'on voit mais ça ça vient des tripes
[Musique]